today was the day that the chancellor
could have put a windfall tax on oil and
gas producers to provide
real help to families
but he didn't
today was the day the chancellor could
have set out a proper plan to support
businesses and create good jobs
but he didn't
today was the day that he could have
properly scrapped his national insurance
hike
he didn't
we said it was the wrong tax at the
wrong time
the wrong choice
today the chancellor has finally
admitted he got that one wrong exactly
inflation is at its highest level for 30
years and rising
energy prices at record highs
people are worried sick
for all his words it is clear that the
chancellor does not understand the scale
of the challenge
he talks about providing security for
working families
but his choices are making the cost of
living crisis worse
not better
mr speaker
the situation following putin's criminal
assault on ukraine
remains gravely serious
just one month after the invasion so
much has changed with repercussions for
years to come
but the chancellor has failed today
to explain why he chose to sign off on a
reduction in our country's armed forces
last october
will the chancellor confirm
if the government's target army size is
still being reduced by 10 000 troops
and let me say this to the chancellor
labour will support whatever is needed
on defense and security to keep our
country safe
[Applause]
mr speaker
the tremors following putin's aggression
will impact on britain
including economically
but the cost of living crisis predates
putin's attack on ukraine
in october inflation was already
forecast to be double the bank of
england's target
and yet the prime minister said
that fears of inflation were unfounded
today we learned that inflation has
reached 6.2 percent and is expected to
go higher in the coming months
people are rightly looking to their
government to help them weather this
storm
labor will support sensible measures to
ease this pressure
but what the chancellor has announced
today says everything we need to know
about his priorities
the cost of living crisis
is heating hitting people particularly
hard
because incomes have been squeezed
during the last 12 years of conservative
governments
ordinary families
disabled people
pensioners
facing really difficult choices
mums skipping meals so that their
children don't
families struggling to buy new school
shoes and uniforms for their children
older people hesitating to put their
heating on because they're worried about
the cost
at the weekend the chancellor was asked
about fuel poverty and he didn't even
know the numbers
it is shameful that he doesn't
because when martin lewis predicts that
10 million people could be pushed into
fuel poverty the chancellor should sit
up and listen
and we know that pensions and security
are not going to keep up with inflation
pensioners and those on social security
will be getting a real terms cut in
their incomes cutting the pension so
what analysis has the chancellor done on
the impact of benefits being uprated by
less than inflation
how many more children and pensioners
will drift into poverty because of the
choices of this government
cutting the pension and who does the
chancellor prioritize
he continues to defend the record
profits of oil and gas producers who
themselves admit that they have more
money than they know what to do with
bp describes this crisis as a cash
machine for them
but it is british people who are paying
out
and it is deeply regrettable that the
snp have joined the tories in wanting to
shield oil and gas producers from
labour's progressive measures
when i
when i set out
when i set out
when i set out labour's plans for a
windfall tax in january
we estimated
that it would have raised 1.2 billion
pounds
now because of the continued rise in
global oil and gas prices
it would today raise over 3 billion
pounds
that's money that could be used
to help families and pensioners and
businesses
with a cut to vat a real brexit dividend
that would help working families and
pensioners across our country
and a targeted warm homes discount that
would see
families and pensioners on the lowest
and modest incomes being supported by
600 pounds
now that today the chancellor comes
along
after 12 years of failure on energy
efficiency and announces a v8 cut on
building materials
this is wholly inadequate
a proper energy efficiency scheme like
the one we have set out could cut bills
by 400 pounds to people from next year
and the silence from the chancellor
on our energy intensive manufacturing
industries is appalling
at this time of national crisis people
and businesses need a government that is
on their side
now the chancellor spoke of difficult
choices
and i agree
there are always choices to be made
like hoot attacks
and who to shield
despite the chancellor's reluctant
measures the facts are that he is still
taking money out of people's purses and
wallets with an increase in national
insurance contributions
the changes that he is making today
begs the question
why did he embark on these changes in
the first place
despite the warnings from the labour
party and from many many others now
it's one thing for the prime minister
and chancellor to disagree with each
other
but the centerpiece of the statement
that the chancellor has delivered today
is based on a disagreement with himself
and for all his tax rising
on millions in the middle where is the
increased tax contribution for the very
wealthiest in society
a landlord with a large number of
properties won't be paying a penny more
in taxes
but their tenants will
someone with significant income from
buying and selling stocks and shares
won't be paying any more in tax
but those people powering our economy
well the chancellor has made the wrong
choices
now the chancellor says
we can't help everyone and that's
absolutely true
but who has the chancellor been helping
out
those who have been swindling the
taxpayer
the chancellor left open the vaults for
widespread waste
crony contracts and a frenzy of fraud
it was as his former tory treasury
minister put it
happy days if you are a crook
7 billion items of ppe not usable and
now being burnt
tax payers money literally going up in
smoke
three and a half billion pounds worth of
contracts awarded to friends donors and
pub landlords
and it gets worse
the chancellor has been signing checks
to fraudsters including organized
criminals and drug dealers
let's put the chancellor's fraud failure
in context
he has lost a staggering
11.8 billion pounds of public money to
fraud
this is twice the amount that a previous
conservative government lost on black
wednesday
as a result of let's face it this
jaw-dropping incompetence the
conservatives have been funding crime
instead of fighting it
and now the chancellor has the audacity
to come to british taxpayers asking them
to pay more to fill his black holes
but there can be no cover-up to hide
political embarrassment
let's call in the national crime agency
to investigate
we need answers people held to accounts
because let's be clear
taxpayers want their money back
the truth is mr speaker
people can no longer afford the
conservatives
working families can't
pensioners can't and businesses can't
the weak growth forecast we've seen
today
should be flashing red on the
chancellor's desk
and the chancellor says in his statement
today that the work starts today
[Music]
is he serious
the conservatives have been in
government now for 12 years
not 12 hours
what has taken them so long
because
since his party entered government the
uk has experienced the biggest downgrade
in growth of any major economy
with the last labour government economic
growth was 2.1 a year
under the last 12 years of the
conservatives it's averaged 1.5 percent
and now we know that growth has been
downgraded this year too
now growth is essential
for funding our public services
keeping taxes under control
and keeping a handle on public finances
too
that's why labor have announced a tough
set of fiscal rules to get our debts and
our deficit down
but the truth is that because of this
government's failure to get the economy
growing
it's this chancellor that has to put up
taxes on families and businesses are
staggering 15 times
this chancellor
has raised taxes more in the last two
years
than any previous chancellor in the last
50.
now he says it's all down to the
pandemic but the truth is the
conservatives have become the party of
high taxation because they are the party
of low growth
[Applause]
now
i understand that the chancellor has a
portrait of nigel lawson above his desk
well
today we've got an energy price crisis
record prices at the prompt pumps
inflation is back
the truth is
he's not nigel lawson mr speaker
he's ted heath
with an instagram account
labor would be getting the economy
firing on all cylinders
ensuring that we buy make and sell more
in britain scrapping business rates and
replacing them with a fairer system fit
for the 21st century something that
small businesses and high street
businesses are crying out for and the
chancellor mentioned it not at all in
his statement today
a climate investment pledge to
decarbonize the economy create good jobs
in every part of britain and strengthen
our energy security too
businesses are seeing unprecedented
increases in their costs right now but
all we hear from this chancellor today
is a promise of jam tomorrow rather than
the support that is needed now
and today's statement
lacks the long-term plan for
productivity skills and growth
where is it chancellor
mr speaker
i can't help but feel
that in both the chancellor's recent
maze lecture
and in his statement today
we are presented with increasingly
incredible claims
perhaps the chancellor has been taking
inspiration from the characters in alice
in wonderland
or should i say alice in sunak land
because nothing here
is quite as it seems either
it's the sort of place
where a chancellor celebrates giving
people 200 pounds
to help them with their spiraling energy
bills before explaining that he needs it
all back exactly in sunnaclan the
chancellor proclaims i believe in lower
taxes while at the same time as hiking
alice's national insurance contributions
so alice asks the chancellor
when did lower taxes mean higher taxes
has down really become the new up yeah
the chancellor follows humpty dumpty's
advice and says
when i use the word
it means just what i choose it to me
neither more
nor less
now alice knows that under the
conservatives taxes
are at their highest level
in decades as a result of the policies
of this very same child
in fact
this chancellor was the only g7 finance
minister to raise taxes on working
people during this crucial year of
recovery
curiouser and curiouser
as alice climbs out of the rabbit's hole
to leave sunak land she recalls the
words of the white rabbit and
concludes that perhaps the chancellor's
reality is just different from yours
the actual reality mr speaker
is that this chancellor's failure to
back a win for tax and his stubborn
desire to pursue a national insurance
tax rise
are the wrong choices
in eight days time people's energy bills
will be rising by 54
two weeks today the chancellor's latest
tax hike will start hitting working
people and their employers
his national insurance tax rise was a
bad idea last september and he's
admitted it's an even worse one today
the chancellor is making an historic
mistake
today was a day to scrap the tax rise on
jobs today was the day to bring forward
a windfall tax
today was the day for the chancellor to
set out a plan to support british
businesses
but on the basis of the statement today
and the misguided choices of this
chancellor
families and businesses will from now on
ensure significant hardship as a result
the chancellor has failed to appreciate
the scaling scale of the challenge that
we face
and yet again he is making the wrong
choices for our country